we posted a poll on our YouTube channel
Community page with the question do you
trust film Distributors the poll
received over 8 000 votes 85 percent of
those polls said they do not trust film
distributors
how do you feel about the negative
reputation surrounding Distributors so
I'm going to be a little contrarian on
this one um
I think there are bad predatory
Distributors out there and I think there
was a time when there was a lot more of
them but so I'm not saying that bad
Distributors don't exist they're not out
there or there's not even a lot of them
maybe there's a lot of them but I I
think that
80 I would say 80 of the negative
chatter around filmmakers and
Distributors stems from filmmakers
misunderstanding of how distribution
actually works and what the market will
bear for their movie like I've seen
filmmaker after filmmaker saying this
distributor ripped me off they're lying
to me I know my movie made more than
this then
nine times out of ten it didn't you know
like it didn't like they're like a movie
your movie is not entitled
to make money in the market you know
like some of them don't you can have you
know like death day for example like
it's it's not the best movie in the
world but it is it's competent it has
all of the like sellable elements it's
all in Focus you know it's it you know
it's it it should have done better but
it didn't and it wasn't like the
distributor hiding numbers from me or
anything is like it just didn't do well
and I think a lot of times it's easier
for us to point the finger and say it's
their fault or they're lying or they
cheated then the movie just didn't do
well you know and I think that's what
happens a lot of the time and then the
other thing is you know it's just in
contracts and you know a distributor is
a business they're looking to make money
so the first contract they give you it's
going to be boilerplate or it's going to
be you know skewed to favor them you
know I have never I haven't worked with
one distributor well maybe one that
wouldn't negotiate a contract so like if
if you don't do your due diligence and
don't realize that hey I made a fifty
thousand dollar movie and a thirty
thousand dollar sales cap is crazy if if
you don't know that and you sign a
thirty thousand dollar sales cap
it's kind of like you know I'm not
saying it's all your fault but you
didn't you signed a bad deal you know
like you had the contract you know you
should know that thirty thousand on
fifty is a like that's a bad deal that's
a red flag you know or you know these
companies that are running around now
trying to trying to like have filmmakers
sign 25-year contracts like that's
that's ridiculous in this day and age
you know so like you should if and if
you don't know that you need to educate
yourself so like if you're gonna go out
and look for a distributor and you know
know the points on the contract
educate yourself you know like there are
and the thing that makes me mad is like
today there's no shortage of information
out there about these Distributors you
know and the ones that are bad that are
really predatory like you can you can
find it pretty quick I mean you can
Google predatory distributor and and
these names will pop up you know like
avoid them it's so I I you know there
are situations like distributor where
like that was like straight up that no
fault of the filmmakers like that
happened that was a horrible like bad
situation you know and there are
Distributors out there that are doing
like really shady crap and you know
again and no fault of the filmmaker but
I would say more often than not a lot of
the negative things around them is is
it's just it's just not understanding
distribution
and these boilerplate contracts how many
pages are they I mean it could be
anywhere from you know I've seen some
that are single pages but I've seen
others that are you know 10 or 12 Pages
they are and then they're long you know
and like and I don't understand all the
ins and outs of contracts but you know I
go to other producers that are more
experienced if I'm dealing with a new
distributor and I'll give it to them or
you know and I know a lot of people like
well I can't afford a lawyer but you
know you can you can get a lawyer to
look at an entertainment attorney to
look at a contract for a few hundred
dollars you know and I and I know that
sounds you know whatever maybe that's uh
you know like an entitled like hey a few
hundred dollars it's nothing but if
you're looking at making money on your
movie you have to you have to take some
of these safeguards so if you don't know
the distributor and don't have a
relationship with them or don't know
anybody that does get out there and find
somebody that does like it's really easy
to track down other producers now you
can go on 9db Pro look up a distributor
click on 10 or 12 of the movies that
they've distributed and start contacting
producers you know and you know some of
them won't want to talk to you some of
them will [ __ ] you but you talk to
enough you can get a lay of the land and
then have a lawyer look at the contract
or somebody that you trust that has more
experience than you and go from there
and when you did take a contractor
contracts to an attorney were there
certain things that were eye-opening to
you where you kind of thought oh yeah
this sounds fine it's legalese for
something but I'm sure it's fine and
then they pointed out oh this is
actually a red flag
um not not really I I mean for me I I've
I've been fairly lucky with with two
exceptions uh with Distributors
um and most of the things that I got
back was just like kind of just what I
mentioned before like uh one of them was
like this is too long a license term
like they wanted 10 years and they're
like you know you should get this down
to no more than seven probably five you
know or they would say that their sales
cap on this is twenty five thousand
dollars uh your movie was budgeted at
42. that's half of your budget like
that's probably more than what and and
honestly if you're talking about lower
end Distributors and anybody that's
trying to charge any more than fifteen
thousand to me that's a red flag
red flag like because I I you see it
over and over they there's no way
they're putting in you know uh thirty
thousand dollars into promotion of those
movies you know they make a one sheet
maybe a trailer you know every now and
then some of these Distributors will
really get behind like a single movie
and they might spend that but I think
most of the time they do not so I just
don't I
unless my movie was starting to get over
the hundred thousand dollar range I
wouldn't even consider a distributor
with a with a sales cap over 15. why do
we often hear that filmmakers are not
making money with their Distributors
however we often hear the other side
from people who work in the business
that you can make great money in
distribution
so
I think some of it is you know
aggressive greener on the other side
stuff I think some of it is just like
not true like I I've talked to you know
like I've talked to several you know
Distribution Company owners over the
past you know three or four years like
doing my channel and whatnot and you
know they have they have to present a
sunny
front like things are good you know the
movies are making money but you know
when you actually get into the
nitty-gritty and look at the numbers
overall generally the like they're not
so you know I so I I think some of it is
from that and I think I think also you
know usually there's so many different
levels of movies and I think some of the
some of the filmmakers aren't
necessarily like at the same level that
some of the Distributors are that are
that are making more money so like say
you hear uh I'm just going to name a
distributor off the top of my head
somebody like uh like gravitas Ventures
is saying like we had a great year with
you know and and maybe they did but you
know they they're representing you know
over 2 000 titles so maybe they had luck
with a certain type of movie and maybe
your movie is not that type of movie you
know what I'm saying so I I think I
think it is such an individualized thing
film distribution and it's so based on
an individualized film like you know
I've just sat here and talked for three
hours about generalities right but it's
all specific to the film into the
filmmaker so you know like a company
could be doing great overall but your
individual film might totally flop with
them and then and the other thing with
that you know people you hear this all
the time filmmakers talk about uh you
know Distributors like oh if I was with
this distributor instead of that one the
movie would have done so much better
it it wouldn't you know they're all
going to the same places they're all
getting to the same platforms they're
all doing the same basic amount of
marketing or no marketing you know it's
like it's all the same you know like
people ask me all the time like you know
what are you because I do Indie rights
and film Hub a lot which do you prefer
which is better
I mean I've had I've had movies make
more with one movies make more with the
other it just it it just depends on the
movie you know and that movie
you know there's no way to tell for sure
but I'd make a thousand dollar bet that
I want to believe would have made just
about the same amount of money with film
Hub as it did with Indie rights or you
know something that did really well with
film Hub like alien contact team my dad
might have done the exact same thing
with it you probably would have done the
exact same thing with India rights in
general
the movie is going to make the same it's
going to get in the same places there's
some Distributors that have you know
like a few better connections you know
maybe with this platform or that
platform maybe they'll get a slightly
better deal or maybe this maybe this
company has a good relationship with
shutter and you're doing horror movies
and maybe they maybe they're good to go
for for that but generally speaking
they're all getting to the same place
they're all making the same amount of
money so it comes down to who do you
trust who is transparent who is going to
pay you and who's going to pay you on
time and who's not gonna you know
screw you over and you know in my
experience you know Distributors like
Indie rights or distribution platforms
like film Hub they are trustworthy
they're straight up they're transparent
you know to me it's a no-brainer you
know like I there are Distributors out
there that people would say like well
you know maybe maybe your film would do
better if you went to like Vision films
and and
maybe it would but I but I would say
that the amount that I'm paying on sales
fees and the extra stuff that they
charge to do those extra things might
not be worth the more money you're
making
would you say if someone can't afford an
attorney that may be distribution
is not for them because they could end
up hurting themselves severely
that's that's that's that's a good
that's a good point
um I I would yeah I that's something to
consider
but but again I you know I I've signed
I've signed a few contracts without ever
going to an attorney but like just
talking to other producers or you know
doing the IMDb thing and contacting
other producers and at the end of the
day
you know everything's a risk like it's
it's all a risk self-distribution is a
risk distribution is a risk you know
doing it yourself going it with them
like there's never a you know a sure
thing and there's never a
you just you never know at a certain
point like filmmaking it's it's a trust
fall you know at a certain point you
either jump in or or get out you know so
you know like I like I wouldn't go to a
new distributor with craving you know
like I wouldn't do it you know like
there's too much on the line for it and
yeah sure maybe I would have you know a
better chance to get to like Netflix or
Hulu or something if I went with a
bigger distributor but distributor that
maybe I haven't worked with to me it's
just like it's not worth it
you know and I know that's easy for me
to say having worked with different
distributors and having choices but you
know I'm I'm telling you if people if
you if you trust what I'm saying like
like Indie rights out there there they
are trustworthy they'll get you on
platforms you'll get paid you know and
they're they're one they're good you
know and there are others but like
they're they're the ones I would say
that because I've had the most
experience with